pleased to say that the vaccine
deployment minister nadim zahawi joins
us once again on the program mr zahari
good to have you on once again and
clearly
lots and lots to talk about uh very
specific to your brief but but i wonder
if we can start with
at that which a number of the papers
appear to have picked up on this morning
that there was a meeting yesterday of
the prime minister's senior ministers
at which it was discussed uh that
whether or not
we need to see tougher restrictions or
indeed tougher enforcement
of existing restrictions just talk to us
a little bit about that thank you very
much uh
neil for having me on so the lockdown is
is
actually pretty severe we're asking
people to stay at home
um don't go out if you have to go out
it's only for exercise
this virus loves social interaction and
we are all
pro social animals and it's the worst
thing we do
is to socialize so only going out for
exercise limited time
stay at home we are concerned that uh
for example in supermarkets uh we need
to make sure people actually wear masks
and
follow the one waste rule in
supermarkets and of course
when they are at capacity to operate
safely people wait uh outside
supermarkets so
uh we don't want to go you know
any tougher because this is a pretty
tough lockdown uh what we need is people
to behave as if they've got the virus
and so that we can
bring this virus under control whilst we
vaccinate
and my role is very much focused on
making sure
that we hit that target of mid february
where we
protect those top four categories where
you know 80 plus percent of the deaths
are coming from
just in terms though you mentioned
several times supermarkets there and
also referenced in the papers is there
some way by which we could be applying
pressure on the supermarkets themselves
to ensure that enforcement of the rules
is a responsibility of the supermarkets
and not just of the individuals
well our plea is to everybody uh each
and every one of us
you know these rules are not boundaries
to be
sort of pushed against these rules are
there to try and
make sure we bring this virus under
control reduce
the pressure on the nhs save lives
that's the really important thing
and as i say this virus loves social
interaction i know it's hard
we're all pro-social animals but just
think
every social interaction you may have
that could be an incident
of transfer transmission of the virus
the supermarkets
have done a tremendous job and i want to
complement and thank them all
for the incredible work they've done and
also coming forward
to help with uh you know offer offers
for
areas where we can use for vaccination
uh
hubs and others but ultimately the most
important thing to do now is to make
sure that actually enforcement
and of course the compliance
with the rules when people are going
into supermarkets are
being adhered to i mean compliance is
clearly
something of an issue anecdotally anyone
who took a drive on saturday or sunday
this weekend may have been slightly
struck by the scenes that they saw
people congregating people grabbing
coffees what do you say to those people
who are who are clearly
exploiting loopholes uh within the
covered 19 regulations we're looking at
pictures from victoria park at the
weekend
people have clearly gone out to take
their exercise and just happen to have
bumped into people
i mean are they not simply displaying
the same common sense that the
government told us that dominic cummings
was
all i would say to people is is this
virus loves
social interaction especially this new
variant which is far more infectious
and i know it's hard it's very hard on
us all because as i said earlier we are
all pro-social we want
you know we it's it's in our dna dare i
say that that we socialize but this is
the worst thing we can do
in terms of helping the virus spread
further
we must must must make sure that we only
go out
when we exercise or obviously to get
some necessary um
shopping done but otherwise stay at home
that is the message
if we all follow that rule stay at home
then we will bring the
virus under control and of course the
vaccinations are really beginning to
ramp up
200 000 a day we've done you know an
incredible job this past week fourth to
the 11th of january you will see later
today
when we publish the figures uh we've had
a a
really significant ramp up in
vaccinations
and we'll do the same and more next week
and the week after
and by mid february we will have
protected those top four categories and
then we keep going
beyond that all night so can we just be
very specific when you say that by
mid-february we will have protected
the most vulnerable categories what do
you mean by that do you mean that by
mid-february we're going to see 14
million people having been vaccinated
because that isn't the direction we're
receiving from downing street this
morning
so the top four categories actually for
the uk is 15 million people
um in england it's about 10 12 million
people
um so we would have offered a
vaccination to all those people
uh to make sure that we can protect them
obviously well that's i'm
sorry minister now that is somewhat
different from what you said a second
ago 40 million people would be protected
now that's not the case as you say
it's 14 million people will have been
offered a vaccine
by the middle of february and providing
us a running total of how many people
have been offered a vaccine but
what use is that i mean that just tells
us how good the royal mail and
the mobile phone companies are
communicating we need to know how many
people are going to be vaccinated by
mid-february so
when will the 14 million people have
received their vaccination
you're absolutely right neil uh and when
you when you offer
a vaccination doesn't mean a royal mail
letter it means actually
the vaccine and the the needle and the
jab is ready for you
and so what you'll see us publishing is
the
total numbers of people being vaccinated
uh not being offered
a vaccine and that's the number to hold
us account to
um okay in terms of the rollout itself
the seven
mass vaccination centers will be music
to the ears of people who are waiting
to get there i i do wonder however the
the 45 minute travel
time what happens if for example
an older person is unable to make that
journey this is not their only shot at
getting a shot is it absolutely right
neil it's very important to remember
that
to this week is the first week of the
rollout of the
uh the vaccination center seven as you
introduced in your piece more next week
more the week after
and yes at the moment the six hundred
thousand letters that have gone out
it are two people 80 year old plus uh
in those top two categories and of
course we'll move down the
categories down to the four top
categories
where the travel time is up to 45
minutes
that will obviously change plus they
have the option not to take
uh that particular route and to wait for
their gp
to vaccinate them so they have other
options
and what i want to get to is to make
sure that every
adult in england has the ability to
vaccinate within 10
mile radius of where they live that is
our absolute focus that is what you'll
see
us do we will roll out more vaccination
centers next week and the
week after we'll bring on the community
pharmacies 200 as the prime minister
uh announced at the press conference a
few days ago so
this is an enormous role at the largest
vaccination program in the history of
this country
but i'm confident that through gps
obviously through hospitals that we've
already got 220 plus hospitals
over a thousand gp primary care
networks by the way who are already
supported by pharmacies as well
then the vaccination centers and of
course pharmacies
you will see the ability for
people to get a vaccine become easier
and easier
in days and weeks to come i i wonder if
we might ask but a couple of categories
of people who have been
looking to secure the vaccine more
quickly than the system currently
allows and police officers on the front
line
throughout all of this and now we
understand some of them a small number a
handful obviously 75 of them
are going to be drafted in to start
driving ambulances is it not now time to
start thinking about
you know making sure that the copper
coppers out there on the front line have
a vaccine
sooner rather than later and also just a
related topic
beginning of december we spoke to fred
banning himself who
suffers from stage four bowel cancer
it is a terminal condition and there are
people in his circumstance
who are asking for the vaccine earlier
than than currently so that they can
in essence extend their time with their
family we were told in december the
government was looking at this
i'm just wondering what the state of
play is today
uh like you know you're absolutely right
to talk about
uh sort of police officers teachers of
course
so the phase one uh that i am very much
focused on delivering
is the categories that the joint
committee on vaccination and
immunization have said they've looked at
all
cohorts you know in terms of um
different
uh professions teachers and and police
but actually
the relationship with age and of course
those who are clinically
uh vulnerable to death from the virus
are the ones that we're focused on
because if we can take them out of
harm's way if we can
protect them with the vaccine by
mid-february
if beyond that within two weeks they
would actually get that immunity
then we would have cut the deaths down
by 80 plus percent
and of course once we get through the
whole nine categories that's 99
of deaths some police officers of course
and teachers will actually get the
vaccine because they are
in those categories but we will very
quickly move on to
those other uh critical workers in the
economy
and of course those who are doing an
incredible job like our police
men and women in protecting us and of
course enforcing
the rules at the moment uh will also be
in that
the highest category of phase two
uh mr zawi we will no doubt speak again
very soon for now though thanks very
much indeed thank you